the Big Bang was more than just a
creation of matter it was a creation of
the universe which means a creation of
space and time creating time space and
everything is a pretty neat trick
obviously it happened but so far
physics hasn't figured out how we don't
know why it bang we don't know what bank
we don't know how it's banging all we
know for sure all of existence suddenly
bursts into life
this is the beginning of the first
second when time itself is set to zero
it's the moment when everything we see
all hundred billion galaxies each of
which contains 100 billion stars all of
that material was compressed in a region
which was infinitely small in its first
second the universe evolves more
radically than in the 13.8 billion years
that follow the first second of the
universe was the most important second
the universe ever had and it went
through more stages in that first second
than it has in all the time since so
much happens so quickly that scientists
need a whole new concept of time
four human beings one second can seem
like a very short time but for the
universe an incredible amount can happen
we measure our lives in hours minutes
and seconds but they're useless at the
timescale of creation because the Big
Bang unfolds almost instantaneously we
have taken our understanding of what the
universe was like back from one second
to a tenth of a second 103rd second a
thousandth of a second a millionth of a
second a billionth of a second all the
way back to a time where the laws of
physics as we now know them break down
that far back time must be measured in
unimaginably tiny slivers known as
Planck time
one way of understanding how much
actually happened in the first second is
to think in units of the Planck time the
Planck time being 10 to the minus 43
seconds there's a billion billion
billion billion billion Planck times in
one second there only a billion billion
seconds in the entire history of the
universe
that's far fewer seconds in all of
history since one second to today than
there were from the Planck time to the
first second